il y a un élément nouveau que moi
j'avais jamais vu c'était bon habituel
je vous dis depuis une trentaine
d'années les attaques de l' trop de
bouton qui sont effectivement
dramatiques pour les éleveurs qui font
que aujourd'hui il y a un pâturage qu'on
abandonne le le 8 août alors qu'avant
l'abandonné début
septembre à cause du problème que vous
connaissez des des louves qui apprennent
à le Louvet à chasser à la fin août
début septembre et nous on a fait qui
est nouveau c'est le fait que nous on
prend en pension des des beau vins on a
un tropau de 300 beau vins et les loups
maintenant les les meutes s'attaquent au
beau vin puis les les méthodes de
d'attaque des mamouthes il y a toutes
les méthodes attaque le vautre é habitué
de temps en temps il y a il y a un VO
après la la naissance qui disparaissait
bon c'est pas c'est pas dramatique mais
aujourd'hui c'est on envoie les beau
vins dans dans les ravins et vous savez
ce qu'est un beau vin une vache dans la
montagne vous savez que les brouvain ne
marchent qu'à l'horizontal
ou quand il marche à la descente ou à la
montée c'est pas pas à pas comme un
enfant de 1 an donc vous
imaginez une fois qu'ils ont découvert
ça dans la dans la dans la meute alors
ensuite il enseignent l'ouveton et on
finit nous vous parliez du problème
économique je réfléchis en disant mais
où est-ce qu'il y a un problème
économique qui est majeur nous le le le
pâturage puisqu'on prend des beaux vins
en estive à peu près 100 l'estive garder
s ENF tout est tout est compris et ben
il y a des éleveurs qui veulent plus
nous envoyer leur
vache donc nous comment on fait et et
autant ça je peux je suis je suis témoin
il y a une grande efficacité parce que
nous soutenons i énormément les
louftiers ils sont d'un dévouement al il
y a un problème de statut bon ce sont
des gens qui sont des bénévoles ils sont
pas assez considérés mais moi je peux
vous dire qu'ils sont efficaces vous
avez une attaque vous savez que vous
avez des des loups qui attaquent sur un
pâurage à partir du moment où le le
préfet nous a doné autorisation de tir
vous envoyez des loutier je peux vous
dire qu' lunette thermique c'est réglé
le loup il a aucune chance c'est que le
loup est un gibier ça veut dire que loup
passe toujours au mêmes endroit donc ça
c'est et il y a ça et deuxièmement ce
dont il se méfie pas c'est la nuit il
est convaincu que la nuit il échappe au
contrôle de l'homme partir vous AZ une
lunette thermique c'est fini et c'est
pour ça que les les les écolos poussés
pour que on on éclaire si vous donz du
jour au loup vous vous l'attrapez jamais
par contre la nuit il se laisse savoir
donc au niveau des au niveau des des
bvins c'est ce que je vous disais on n
pas de méthode on sait pas comment on va
faire
et pour les pour lesov puis j'en ai
terminé avec cette cette observation on
arrive à peu près à s'en sortir vous
avez de bons bergers alors ça ça devient
de plus en plus difficile c'est un vieux
berger qui s'occupe bien de son troupeau
qui il y arrive avec des avec des chiens
de protection euh par
contre pour le les les beau vins alors
je reviens à ce que disait Monsieur le
Préfet référence c'est vrai que on a vu
peut-être une baisse de nombre de
victimes mais sur les EAU vins et
j'aimerais voir comment ça va se passer
pour les beau vins et qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire on peut pas mettre un chien Patou
derrière chaque beauin mais c'est pas
possible c'est je sais pas comment les
choses vont se dérouler